why'd you go through his phone
is doing something doji yeah I wouldn't
do it unless I had a suspicion
um and I had a suspicion and I was right
and every time I've done it I've been
right would you find but now I've got to
a point where I will never do it because
every time I've done it I've found
something and I actually really like my
boyfriend so I like even if I get the
feeling I'm like
just leave it at this point
but what did you find uh naked pictures
from other girls oh wow yeah he was but
like how I used to get her all the time
my ex-girlfriend like girlfriends have
had they've gotten one Pacific partner
has gone through my phone and woke me up
at like three in the morning been like
oh blah blah blah I'm like but how did
you know and I've been I don't know I
don't know we're not continuous but my
younger days
like I would just be like but how did
you even know I was talking to her on
Facebook or how did you know well I
couldn't answer that one what what made
you think a woman always knows I'm like
what is this how does that means
there's a lot of subconscious things
that you would do yeah okay so it's like
we pick up on little social cues that
like men don't right so like okay we'll
see
it we'll we'll notice let's say if you
don't like text us around the time you
normally text us yeah or like or if you
don't do something you normally do that
you wouldn't like think anything of like
women we notice yeah we notice
everything or if like you have a certain
interaction with a girl and you think
well that's how we used to interact with
me I liked when we first met because the
thing is the thing is guys have this as
well and guys you know the whole the
whole thing of like guys knowing who
that one guy friend who's actually
trying to [__] guys also see this as
well so we understand this it's very
it's kind of different how we go about
dealing with it so guys we'll go go
around be like oh that one friend we'll
just say it directly because guys are
way more direct than women we're like yo
that friend Zeke or whatever his name is
Zach or I'm trying to think of random
names oh Zach's trying to [__] you like
there's gonna be no one where guys will
tell their girlfriend no no it's not
a girl will do
the same information and instead of just
saying outright like you know Sarah was
trying to have sex with you bro it'll be
like they'll they'll go around and like
get you to see it through their words
type of thing you know what I mean very
different approaches that guys the
approach that we take sometimes as guys
is like we think that that's gonna
repost the girl the girl like sex bro
and she likes to the attention if you
say you know you know that male friend
he wants to [__] you know everybody
you know I mean she probably knows
already but you know at the end of the
day that's why I feel like with male
friends
um with women and guys like having that
friendship is very much um it works in a
woman's favor all the time so you want
to be friends with your girl sorry
no you you know
we're good we're good but but I would I
would treat you like a male friend that
she has in it so the boundaries will be
there ain't no let's get changed
together you can't come in one day and
you're in the chain all right listen to
this yeah I once had a girl or she she
wanted to come around my yard and and
work or something and she was like oh a
boyfriend won't allow it because it's
just me and her I was like but why
though it's just me and her she's
working from instead of working from
home
her boyfriend said no yeah yeah it's
about her not being in a space or in a
situation where something could happen
there should be boundaries in place if
you're interested relationship there's a
friend of mine he's a good friend he was
a good friend of mine yeah but like put
like this I was in a situation where I
hope to go do her assignment but by the
end of the night did we finish the
assignment no
you finished another thing
one-on-one
two races and those type of times I can
100 understand that the guy being like I
feel a bit away you think your face you
even
I can see
you just don't want to put yourself in a
situation where something could come
back let's say the girl lies and you
can't really defend yourself it's her
word against yours I think that there
should be boundaries in place like I
don't think it's okay if you are if
she's in a relationship it's not okay
for her to be bopping up to your room to
work like why I don't understand there's
no but you're just chilling you're
working from home you usually work from
home did you when she said that to you
did you say you know I understand that's
a really like you that's great your
boyfriend had boundaries or did you say
oh that's horrible I said to her but he
knows I'm vital that doesn't help
I've even have been intimate before we
we no we haven't we go in a situation
where I knew she had feelings for me
I'm a nice guy
[Music]
okay I want to know if if you got I know
you're not single but for this when you
were single if you guys would respond or
not and what you would think of him
you know I can't really see is that your
car I feel like if I saw this Instagram
I would think probably that's the one
that they gave me yeah that's the one
that the Gators went to one
yeah
but I don't think that's
like this is one of these type of
problems you've got blue ticks coming
into yours as well wow
oh yeah definitely yeah yeah yeah yeah
is that Magnum
okay uh would you guys what do you guys
think what would you like the last
picture in this picture is fine there
was a couple pictures that would be like
um
yeah
so would you guys respond
yeah probably yeah yeah what about you
two would you respond no
I don't know I think you're a good
looking guy but I don't know because of
course you had your you were flexing
[Laughter]
things
no yeah no I mean you're a good looking
guy but I think yeah there was a couple
of pictures that I'm
um
it's just yeah something I well yeah
but it's I mean I think I have that view
in general though like even if a girl is
like and I'm not gonna say I haven't
done this in the past but if you're out
there like bikini like tits like tits in
the camera like showing off your body in
a certain type of way you want a certain
type of attention like I can't take you
seriously
I agree
I just have like I would think
because when you see a profile like that
I would just assume you get so much
attention yeah you're saying it's true
and so I'm like I'm not a headache no
I'm too jealous
you know I mean you're a demon as many
of you know I was just banned on Tick
Tock and we are demonetized on a daily
basis on this platform if you want to
help please consider sending a super
thanks below every donation helps and it
helps make what we do possible